what's up guys yo over our process of
filming bel air i can really call this
dude my brother
and we've just grown to be a huge family
so now we're going to see if we can tell
who's who from back in the day
that's akira i mean yeah look at those
eyes i mean that's the camera yeah
what
wait a minute
are you serious one two three akira
oh
i didn't know
all right okay
that's brilliant this is brilliant
[Music]
[Applause]
let me ask you something like when you
were that age like could you have ever
imagined like everything that's
transpired bro i had a vision yeah yeah
definitely had a vision i knew whatever
i wanted to do i want to do a big you
felt it yeah absolutely yeah for sure
do it one two three adrian yeah
it was straight from here over here also
like why he looked like a grown man
that's aj
wow you've never seen him with so much
hair is that a link or is that uh
it's college it's a human length
yeah that's jimmy he looks like he feels
like this is my afro first says this is
my fro oh an afro wait who that soul who
got an effort to say nah nah
nah
yeah yeah yeah
jimmy jimmy is your final answer that's
me oh geez
how believe this what is wrong with me
who is that bro i don't know who that is
that is jordan
jordan little old man
jordan
that dude he still looked just like
still looks like he still makes that
face jordan jordan
that picture is so old
you see you see you see the paper you
see how
i think that's
this one right here that's your mama
[Music]
no
oh
yeah
all right three two one akira
oh
that's a cute
[Music]
i'mma guess it's ollie that's it
oh he's smiling oh wow wow look at that
oh you're such a happy little dude i
know right wow young people smile that's
yeah
three
two one
the afro is a lot smaller it's just a
lot of smaller oh and that little face
he's like you can trust me okay
oh bless his heart that's jimmy yeah
yeah
that's only that's definitely it looks
exactly like this right now
come on we wouldn't be family if we
didn't poke fun at each other i know if
only we could tell those little kids
there'd be a mansion in our future
so stream bel air on blue duck
[Music]
you